so next round of
CFK from Canada
yes, I saw this idea once, it
was a bit strange but
with you six D5 but it is questionable
whether all this has achieved so much here
so um where are we going now the
five
yes at least one original one  Position
yes no idea
runner the four maybe
and then six years anyway probably
just a solid thing
as he can maybe play the tensioner the
four
okay probably great paid attention to it
so now back then maybe
F4 and G3 are hanging
yes I can't recommend just
taking it now so stupid
That's somehow a problem
so
that I can go back to F3 and
that's normal, surprising
so somehow it wouldn't be that
bad, okay,
so now I'll take the
opportunity to go to F5, which wasn't without
problems, comes to E4 or  he has to
take away and then I really have
everything in the center, it's
a bit slow now, of course, but
can you still cover everything
right away, king the seven, just
like that, yes G4 should also make
it more difficult, it's still easy to do, well,
as I meant the hair building
potentially  That's a weakness,
so well, of course he has
fields like C4 A5 here and
he doesn't want to go there, so he just
tested it out for a moment,
like a king G6
tried something like knight H5, swaps it
away,
that's totally crazy, I just have
one more why  I
swapped everything here too, or I'm now
totally not understanding it can't be
that much of a problem here, the structure being built, well,
okay, it's not easy to
move on, maybe it
can be, well, let's
see,
okay, but that can't be the case now  Here
the knight also breaks itself,
but it's still not so clear to see
how to move forward.
At least at the moment I don't see anything
if he just plays King G3 F3 all the time.
Here, how do you get there
?  not whether you can get further
away from
an i5
because the knight is dead,
maybe it's a pressure to move in
some way
that you still get to E4 in the end,
so yes, well then I can
pick it up again with the bishop,
at least you can do that
It's probably not necessary, but
at least it's
okay
and now E4
check.de
he has to draw the king again. Wait, but
hopefully it's
won now.
I have to take it, I have to do
it  not won that would be
really disappointing
so
I gave you five notices 3 C4 BC King c5c3
would be that for me
I ca
n't give you any more time
that was won of course I'm so
slow
game
maybe that would really be unfair somehow
yes it seems but so to speak
I have to here  really play differently
somehow
still okay I might just have to
pick him up build the arm
I still thought I thought that was a
win,
well